jeanjad bonjour on s'est déjà vu pour
parler au fond de la crise de la
démocratie culturelle hein dont vous
parliez mais je voudrais peut-être qu'on
qu'on revienne quand même à ce aux
actions que vous avez vous avez fait
cette création de la de la compagnie
black blomber euh qui nous ramène à quoi
une 30 30anné pres
d'abord de Me salu je commencer déjà par
vous saluer oui oui qui nous ramène à
presque 30 ans d'histoire comment ça
comment ça se passe au début alors vous
êtes médecin hein oui oui oui tout à
fait comment vous je alors comment bah
moi je é le premier étonné mais ça
correspond à une période de ma vie où je
suis en train de relâcher un petit peu O
je me demande si je vais faire le
médecin généraliste comme disons mon
histoire m destine pour des raisons
personnelles et et là ça commence par la
rencontre que j'ai fait avec un lieu et
avec une personne le lieu c'est la
Maison pour tous deslancour qui est
véritablement un lieu où circulent de
très nombreux artistes Christian Vander
avec
magmaette il y a des gens du Royal de
Luxe qui commencent à se pas du Royal de
Luxe pardon de du magique Circus com des
artistes de C des musiciens ça circule
voilà ça circule et la personne c'est
Christine cou
p est
danseuse fait connaissance ça c'est les
deux éléments le trème élément c'est le
fait de la nécessité l'urgence de
fireille très rapidement puisque oui
c'est ça vous implantez dans un lieu où
qui qui existe d' on vit dans un lieu
qui où les murs sont encore tous à
sortir et où est-ce que on est une vraie
ville quand on consulte l'histoire
qu'est-ce qu'une vraie ville c'est
souvent une ville qui s'est fabriquée
avec dans les remous
dans les méandres cell- n'a pas
d'histoire pour l'instant voilà constru
voilà puis il y a des petites histoires
de différents Bours de 10 à 15 voit
20000 habitants pour trappe à l'époque
enfin pas tout à fait 20000 mais c'était
la la plus grosse bourgade donc tout ça
ça va pas forcément faire ville ça va
pas forcément faire histoire et là je
pense que ce qui était très intéressant
c'est la demande du groupe central des
villes nouvelles qui m'a permis de me
mettre en rapport avec les équipes
artistiques donc j'ai répondu à une
offre à une demande d'étude et j'ai
demandé que cette étude soit une étude
action c'est-à-dire que je puisse
expérimenter un certain nombre d'idées
qui allent être mises là au travail en
réflexion en chantier et dans ces idées
bien sûr il y a j'en reviens toujours à
ce que je vous ai dit la dernière fois
c'est la construction d'un nous c'est
opportunité extraordinaire qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire ensemble bah oui pu
puisqu'on va naître ensemble à cette
ville démarrant sur des bonnes bases
hein c'est dans le fond de Black blamb
il y a cette idée voilà il y a aussi de
Gaul qui on en parlait la dernière fois
qui qui promet la citoyenneté à au sujet
musulmanans AR que sont mes parents et
cetera donc c'est c'est un ensemble
voilà et et oui et tout ça alors ça
comment ça se focalise au fond comment
comment ça se crée ben d'abord j'ai mis
en place de nombreuses expériences pas
tout seul hein avec l'aide d'une équipe
d'animation extrêmement importante il y
avait 40 personnes qui travaillaient
dans cette maison pour tous dont le nom
barbare était la pasque mais qui était
le lieu disons de l'association
sociocculturelle de la ville alors je
pense que ça c'est une époque et qu'il
faudrait pas vouloir refaire sacraliser
ouis ni sacraliser ni même refaire je
pense que ce qu'il faut garder d'une
telle époque c'est la participation des
gens de pionnier quoi un peu il y a côté
un pe comme ça quand même he oui pour
nous mais je pense que oui oui pour nous
mais c'est pas ça le plus intéressant
évoquer ce qui est intéressant à mon
avis c'est le fait que les gens
participent les gens font de l'art les
gens ne consomme pas seulement l'art
qu'on a choisi pour eux bien ou pas bien
les gens en font eux-mêmes et comment
vous expliquer alors et un autre point
excusez-moi Patrice ce que les gens ont
à offrir de leur propre capacité
artistique n'est pas considéré comme
mineur n'est pas considéré comme pauvre
on fait pas de jugement non on fait pas
de jugement mais on a quand même une
exigence et le on n'est pas uneemi du
temps ça veut dire que on aura le temps
de comment d'échanger sur la qualité de
nos valeurs là je parle de l'artiste et
de l'habitant et il y a un moment où on
se rendra compte que il y a une
subjectivité de la encore une fois et
que qui peut dire aujourd'hui dans son
propre temps que une œuvre est une
grande vre c'est ça qui va rester on
peut Pasir c'est tellement faux et et en
même temps on est dans les années 80
enfin c'est mit vient d'être élu et ce
les anné de la gauche Jack ministre de
la Culture on va lui reprocher beaucoup
ça Jack on va dire mais au fond est-ce
que vous mettez pas tout sur le même
plan est-ce que vous confondez pas tout
est-ce que toutes les cultures se valent
ça été un des reproches qui été fait bah
je pense que c'est un des reproches à
tort parce qu'on peut lui faire des
reproches à
raison selon mon point de vue mais ah
non le fait qu' un moment donné il donne
la parole
alors donner la parole à tout le monde
ça peut être démagogique après ça dépend
comment on donne cette parole enfin
comment on permet l'accès à gens à
certaines expr
d'émerger je pense que dans les tout
premiers temps de la gauche mais j'ose
dire les 6 premiers mois de la gauche on
était vraiment sur cette posture
absolument mais on était sur cette
posture d'éducation populaire
c'est-à-dire l'art émancipateur euh dès
qu'il a fallu réformer l'ordonnance de
45 dès que miteran a changé de paradigme
qu'il a accepté le paradigme du grand
commerce international c'est déjà
structurellement le début de la fin par
contre on va vivre 5 6 ans sur l'élan
cette sorte de grand élan du vivre
ensemble du début voilà vous faites un
un lien toujours constant quoi entre la
la la culture l'art l'économie la
politique bien sûr bien sûr l'un peut
pas être indépendant de l'autre quoi on
peut toujours évoquer l'art ou une forme
artistique en dehors de son contexte
temporel historique politique et ça ne
me gêne pas de d'être sur des valeurs
purement esthétiques mais l'engagement
d'une compagnie comme la nôtre de gens
comme nous de quelqu'un comme moi c'est
un engagement euh sur connaître
comprendre mettre à jour la mémoire qui
qui nous empoisonne qui qui empoisonne
cette incapacité à vivre entre nous
toutes ces choses qui ne sont pas dites
mais qui sont bien là qui puent
énormément et qui sont dans les repli
des mots des mots qu'on emploie encore
sans le savoir et ça c'est le pire ou en
le sachant enfin je sais pas lequel est
P mais justement vous parlez de de
changement de paradigme économique de la
part de militerran mais il y a aussi à
ce moment-là et et c'est peut-être ce
que vous payez aujourd'hui c'est
peut-être aussi ce qui explique un peu
la montée de du Front national la montée
de l'individualisme aussi et que le nous
que que vous vouliez faire ça devient
plus compliqué non oui alors oui en même
temps ce qui est plus compliqué c'est de
le faire entendre au pouvoir public ou
au bailleurs de fond qui soit privé ou
public pour nous ça pas été si difficile
à entendre parce que dans le rapport au
public aux gens aux gens qui qui
travaillent avec vous qui viennent non
ça ça n'a pas changé d'autant plus que
nous nous développ nous prenons un nous
mais quand on explique ce nous on dit on
dit quoi on dit que c'est d'abord un jeu
qu'on construit quelque chose qu'on
construit par rapport à soi-même et en
même temps par rapport aux autres donc
c'est un peu plus compliqué d'être
simplement individualiste ou d'être
totalement collectiviste cette ce ce
cette notion un peu maniquaine et déjà
largement dépassé je pense qu'il y a un
moment où le le Hipop
le danseur dans la rue il dit à la fois
je au moment où c'est le moment de dire
je c'est quand il est au centre du du
cercle dans le défiou dans battle comme
on dit aujourd'hui en lesanglcism gagné
et euh c'est pas forcément très grave
mais enfin c'est significatif euh et
quand il revient dans le cercle il y a
le nous je pense que c'est la meilleure
image de cette sorte de CIT c'està il
peut pas y avoir un nous de qualité sans
un développement du jeu de qualité sauf
que la finalité de la société c'est pas
un ensemble de jeux côte à côte qu'on
l'air de d'être ensemble je reviens un
petit peu en arrière alors c'est vrai
que bon il y il y a il y a la création
de de votre compagnie et puis il y a il
y a quand même un succès absolument
énorme très vite quand même non ah oui
oui oui même et pousstetouflant et
pousstoufl ouais ouais ouais alors ça
international enfin je dire
international national Absolum national
international bah parce que ça
correspond à quelque chose qui fait qui
a immédiatement du sens on travaille sur
des symboles populaire que les gens
comprennent que les gens connaissent et
sur lequel à partir duquel on développe
une esthétique donc c'est logique ça
touche le plus grand nombre puisqu'on
travaille avec une matière qui est celle
qui s'échange le plus possible dans ce
plus grand nombre donc il y a rien de
surprenant à ça ce qui nous surprend
c'est que les pouvoirs publics et
notamment les gens garants de la culture
la plus raffinée la plus haute culture
c'est leur étonnement qui nous a
étonné l'étonnement l'étonnement de
temps en temp ah benah
l'étonnement on peut rajouter le mépris
mais le seul fait déjà quiil s'étonne
qu'un truc comme ça puisse marcher nous
étonne nous ça veut dire que il ne voit
vraiment pas qui nous sommes et il voit
véritablement pas les autres l'ensemble
de tous les autres mais évidemment le
mépris ça n'est que la petite note euh
bon voilà c'est c'est c'est de la déco
pour garder son genre pour garder sa
classe ça vient de quoi est-ce que les
les gens qui sont les décideurs au fond
de la culture ils sont form dans un
moule oui d'une part et puis il viennent
aussi souvent de de milieu où ils n'ont
pas forcément eu à connaître ou à
ressentir de des pratiques qui peuvent
se développer dans le milieu populaire
comment c'est la la vie d'une compagnie
pour la vôtre aujourd'hui c'est c'est
compliqué c'est dur c'est dur en même
temps à l'heure où on parle et depuis 5
6 années maintenant la ville de trappe
s'est engagée de manière beaucoup plus
importante avec nous et de manière
extrêmement forte maintenant
il y a encore il y a que quelques mois
la ville nouvelle de Saint-Quentin enfin
disons la communauté d'aglo
d'agglomération aujourd'hui de 50 ans
nieline a ouvert un champ qu'on espérait
depuis plus de 20 ans nousou c'est ils
appelle
ça pulsation urbaine mais c'est un cadre
qui n'existait pas qui reconnaît une
valeur d'expression artistique à des
formes comme les nôtres ou cell du
Déclic Théâtre ça n'existait pas dans
les outils de la vie nouvelle enfin de
de
Saint-Quentin on pouvait retrouver ça
que dans le j'allais dire le guichet
culture ou le guichet politique de la
ville pour nous c'est une évolution
extrêmement importante c'est drôle dire
parler de Déclic Théâtre parce que c'est
aussi une démarche qui qui est la foi
citoyenne comme la vôtre citoyenne
populaire et culturelle qu'est-ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter alors bah de durer
en fin de compte parce que
ça d'être capable comment dirais-je
d'être le lieu où en
permanence les choses peuvent se
renouveler peuvent se redire se repenser
ou les distances qu'on a par rapport à
soi-même et par rapport aux autres
peuvent être recalculé si je puis dire
tant qu'il y aura des lieux de cette
nature là on pourra véritablement parler
de démocratie culturelle voire de
démocratisation mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut oser la
démocratie culturelle il faut se rendre
compte que il y aura pas de changement
économique il y aura pas de r politique
par par exemple si déjà les gens ne
décident pas eux-mêmes de progresser
vers une sorte de vivre ensemble une
sorte de nous qui ne peut se construire
qu'avec leur assentiments vous vous
n'avez jamais pensé baisser les bras non
non non non non parce que quand je bouge
les bras je P je pense pas j'allais dire
non c'est l'action pendant l'action si
si il y a eu des moments de de
découragement mais enfin bon la dernière
fois ça a duré 24 heures je suis d'une
bonne nature je tomberai je pense tout
d'un bloc alors vous souhaite beaucoup
de courage et et encore de beaucoup
beaucoup d'action merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup